es gibt schon wieder einen corona
ausbruch auf bei einem schlachtbetrieb
diesmal ist es wiesenhof 66 leute sollen
in der firmenzentrale sich angesteckt
haben
jan vor dem betrieb in lohne steht jetzt
für uns michael engelberg mich haben
gerade gehört 66 infizierte gibt es
jetzt dort muss man jetzt damit rechnen
dass es ähnlich wie bei dennis und den
landkreisen gütersloh und warendorf zu
einem lok dann kommt ja guten am nil
also das ist natürlich das wäre der
worst case das versucht man natürlich im
landkreis vechta zu verhindern das hat
der herr landrat winkel heute auch
gesagt die frage ist natürlich gekommen
mit der zahl von 41,7 nicht mehr
natürlich nur knapp unter 50 wir haben
aber danach nach der pressekonferenz des
landkreises mit einigen leuten hier
gesprochen in lohne und da ist die angst
schon groß dass vor allen dingen die
unternehmer werden mit einem taxifahrer
gesprochen er sagte
also ganz ehrlich wenn es hier zu einem
lockdown kommen würde könnte er seinen
betrieb dicht machen aber das ist
natürlich das was der landkreis versucht
wirklich zu vermeiden
allerdings hat der leiter des
gesundheitsamtes der stellvertretende
leiter des gesundheitsamtes auch gesagt
dass er davon ausgehe dass eventuell
eine dunkelziffer von den leuten die in
quarantäne sich befinden dass da
vielleicht noch mal 20 dazu kommen und
die würden nur getestet wenn symptome
auffallen würden das vielleicht auch so
ein ja ob es ein kleiner kleiner trick
ist man weiß es nicht auf jeden fall
gibt es keine freie testung und jetzt
muss man natürlich die nächsten tage
abwarten